I think it's fascinating the type of
attention that goes to kind of
everything that you say yeah whether you
mean it to be something big absolutely
yeah
what's that scrutiny like for you it's
there's a there's a right now us sitting
is real yeah everything else is is it
there's so many things that change it
it's like broken telephone you know like
I say one thing and all right tweet one
thing in a million articles rewrite it
in a different way by the time you might
see it it already went through 50
different platforms and you're reading
nothing compared to what nothing like
what I said yeah so if people want to
know what how I actually feel and what I
actually think go watch a live interview
like right now you know and go come and
find me on the street and ask me what I
think I think it's up to people to not
believe every single thing that they see
on media yeah you know because it's
broken telephone do you feel like when
people do that like when this broken
telephone we're talking about say your
love life or anything personal that they
might have picked up from something that
you've said do you feel the need to
clarify yourself sometimes 90% of the
time no because they don't desert nobody
you don't unless it's something you
actually messed up and said and you feel
you need to clarify if there's something
that you truly don't believe in I don't
think you should feel the you know the
pressure of having to clarify you know
unless you actually did mess up and then
sometimes it gets a little too much and
you're like okay I gotta get online and
I got to clarify this because this is
not what's going on but the more you
feet the more you go online and you
tweet at the article saying that's not
true there you're doing exactly what
they want you're feeding the fire you
know for more articles to mess up what
you said man the collaborations on this
album are spectacular John Mayer Khalid
yankles you've said these are three of
you are like most trusted friends in the
biz yeah why is that what makes your
relationship with them so special
they're just great people in the
simplest way of saying it really genuine
people and they care about music and
they love music and they're fans of me
and I'm fans of them and I think you
know when collaborating with an artist
the first thing that comes to mind is
I love you you're awesome I think you're
so awesome I can't believe I'm working
with you and when that feeling is
reciprocated is what creates magic and
that and I think that we all have that
with each other and yeah this was really
really cool it's no secret that you've
been a major fan of John Mayer for
basically like your entire life yeah
what is a recording session with John
Mayer like it's awesome dude he's he's
so freaking talented and so normal in
the best way and I hate using the word
normal because I think it's just a
stupid word yeah and I but I mean that
like he's just a really really good dude
and he's just extremely talented and he
cares and he cares enough to listen to
anybody no matter even if millions of
people know he's the best guitarist in
the world he still will ask you what did
you just do on guitar what was that you
know like he he he thinks and he and he
cares about what you think no matter who
you are and he wants to learn he wants
to learn that's coming from anybody
there's nothing that's making him feel
like he's the best and that's I admire
that so much about him was there any
moment when you're working with him that
you just kind of were like I think he's
asking me my opinion when he when he
well I'm really good friends of them cuz
we've hung out a bunch and we talked all
the time so that thing kind of went away
from me but when he was soloing I'd like
to be you his it's just it's it's just
different planet yeah it's different
planet guitar playing he's like the
Christiano Ronaldo of guitar playing
seriously yeah you know but yeah um you
know Julian Michael's too is is one of
those people his name like he you just
said Keith Urban told us that when he
sits down with her it's like fluid like
the music just comes out and she seemed
nervous with you what was that session
like and did it just wasn't that way
that song just came out totally it took
us 30 45 minutes to like really write
the song and yeah she just sits and
played you play music to her whatever
chords and if she's just consciousness
flow of consciousness melodies lyrics
concepts excitement it's just all
emotion and I think it's a blessing and
a curse for her because I think it's
tough to be that connected to your
emotions but it's also really beautiful
but yeah she's really insanely talented